Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres le roman d’intrigue ou
d'enquête et paraît-il aussi vieux que
l'épopée de Gilgamesh ou de l'Odyssée
c'est-à-dire aussi vieux que la
littérature elle-même et pourtant il a
longtemps été considéré comme un genre
mineur aujourd'hui ces frontières
s'effacent et hiérarchie symbolisme au
point que Simenon par exemple Simenon
qui disait lui-même j'ai trop de respect
pour la littérature pour considérer que
le roman policier en fait partie et bien
Simon a été admis à la Pléiade ou à peu
près au même moment qu'en Régine caragon
et que Camus alors la littérature
policière est-elle une littérature de
gens ou bien est-elle une littérature
tout court c'est cela dont nous avons
discuté ce soir dans cette émission que
nous avons intitulé roman policier roman
populaire point d'interrogation et nous
allons faire avec deux auteurs qui ont
comme un non seulement d'être normand
tous les deux mais d'avoir des pedigree
scientifique des plus sérieux d'avoir
publié des ouvrages d'octes l'un et
l'autre dans leur discipline l'un la
géographie et l'autre l'histoire de
l'art et cependant d'être des auteurs de
romans policiers adrien Goetz bonsoir
bonsoir Adrien vous êtes lauréat du
concours général normalement de la rue
du agrégée d'histoire docteur en
histoire professeur à la Sorbonne
et vous êtes même académicien membre de
l'Académie des Beaux-Arts et vous êtes
l'auteur de nombreux ouvrages
scientifiques vous êtes l'auteur de 4
romans classiques mais vous avez aussi
publié une série policière dont
l'héroïne est une conservatrice du
patrimoine et
paraît cette année le sixième épisode de
cette série intrigue à Brégançon nous
allons revenir à vous mais nous allons
commencer avec Michel Bussy Michel
bonsoir bonsoir Michel vous aussi vous
êtes professeur vous avez une carrière
universitaire très sérieuse vous êtes la
blessures de géographie spécialiste de
la géographie électorale vous avez
publié sur le sujet une dizaine
d'ouvrages très sérieux vous avez même
dirigé un laboratoire du CNRS à Rouen et
ça c'est docteur jekyde mais il y a
Mister Hyde c'est un phénomène d'édition
vous avez publié une vingtaine de de
d'ouvrages de thriller policiers qui
vous ont hissé à la deuxième place je
crois du podium des auteurs les plus
vendus en France vous avez dû depuis le
début de votre carrière à peu près
vendre une vingtaine de millions
d'exemplaires et vous publiez trois vies
par semaine auprès de la cité
et vous êtes évidemment rentré
immédiatement dans la liste des
best-sellers comme d'habitude j'allais
dire donc l'intrigue c'est on commence
par un cadavre découvert sur les bords
de Meuse sur ce cadavre trois passeports
identiques mais avec des noms différents
des identités différentes et à partir de
là vous allez nouer et dénouer une
intrigue complexe et bien ruée pleine de
rebondissements exactement c'est ce que
j'aime souvent dans des romans pas dans
tous mais avoir une situation de départ
qui paraît quasiment impossible c'est à
dire que là un brave homme qu'on
retrouve des CD qui était marié depuis
30 ans qui avait voilà perte de famille
représentante commerce une vie tout à
fait banale et on découvre qu'il aurait
eu deux autres identités puisqu'ils se
promènent avec deux autres permis de
conduire de jumeaux de Sosie ou de
triplés pourquoi pas sauf que les dates
de naissance c'est le même jour à Paris
amende donc donc dans un désert français
et à Charleville-Mézières dans les
Ardennes donc impossible évidemment
d'être né au même endroit à trois enfin
dans trois endroits différents au même
moment et plus encore de mener trois
vies parallèles dans trois endroits si
différents et pourtant tous les Français
avec c'est le cas alors on peut pas
rentrer dans l'intrigue parce que sinon
on va tout dévoiler est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous imaginez est-ce que vous
avez réfléchi à vos techniques
narratives est-ce que vous avez réfléchi
à vous recettes est-ce que vous avez une
méthodologie de construction de vos de
vos romans il y a forcément quelque
chose qui est complètement artisanal au
départ moi j'ai jamais pris de cours de
d'écriture de ces Dario de quoi que ce
soit donc quand j'écris mon premier
roman je me suis lancé Dory de toutes
mes lectures ou des films ou des BD que
j'avais vu regarder après c'est vrai
comme on pose régulièrement la question
est-ce que vous commencez par la fin
est-ce que vous laissez de la liberté à
vos personnages enfin toutes ces
questions techniques aux Philippines par
réfléchir à ce qu'on fait j'ai publié
dernière chez Le Robert un livre qui
s'appelait l'art du suspense vous
essayez un petit peu de théoriser ce que
peut être l'intrigue à suspense
notamment ce qui est l'intrigue à twist
c'est à dire à rebondissement comme on
disait il y a des nouvelles à chute il y
a une chute à la fin qui qui surprend et
qui retourne la narration donc j'ai
essayé théoriser ce que ce genre là donc
voilà bien sûr mais faut pas oublier que
ça reste essentiellement artisanal et
notamment l'idée de départ d'un livre
l'étincelle qui fait qu'on se dit tire
je vais pouvoir écrire 300 400 500 pages
à partir de cette idée de départ ça ça
reste complètement basique et mystérieux
on voit quand même le géographe non pas
seulement le géographe de géographie
électorale non pas seulement dans la
puissance des lieux qui sont des
personnages à part entière de vos romans
et là en l'occurrence c'est le Cantal
Paris 18e et la Meuse enfin les Ardennes
rimbaldiennes mais non mais parce que
comme vous faites de la géographie
électorale vous faites des statistiques
vous faites des maths et il y a une
espèce de me semble-t-il dans vos romans
de modélisation il y a une construction
quasi mathématique des intrigues et de
ses retournements oui alors c'est vrai
que je trouve que moi je faisais de la
géographie mais de la géographie sociale
je m'intéressais un petit peu moins aux
paysages ou à l'environnement au sens la
morphologie des couches de roche etc que
que la sociologie au sens de la
politique au sens de la démographie
d'urbanisme etc et donc c'est vrai quand
je construis un roman je me tiens ce
roman va se dérouler à faire le ville
bézières je m'intéresse comme tout le
monde à rabot à la Meuse etc mais tout
de suite j'essaie de me dire qu'est-ce
qu'il fait la particularité de faire le
bézières qu'est-ce qui fait la
particularité des Ardennes alors je
découvre ce couloir qu'on appelle la
pointe ou le doigt de JV qu'en fait
cette petite couloir qui s'enfonce dans
la Belgique on sait très curieux je me
renseigne vous dit pourquoi cette
ancienne place forte elle est toujours
là bon donc en fait c'est un travail de
géographe et j'essaye de remettre ça
dans mes romans qui fait que j'espère
que l'immersion dans les lecteurs ce
roman c'est une valse à trois temps où
on est effectivement au pied de la butte
Montmartre avec une héroïne parisienne
qui court du cimetière de Montmartre à
la scène etc puis on est à Charleville
bézières sur les bords de la Meuse dans
ces forêts très sombres de la de des
Ardennes et puis on est dans les Grands
Causses amandes à Florac et donc
j'espère que le lecteur il se dit waouh
je voyage j'y suis et et et en plus ça
me permet de dire des choses sur mes
Héroïdes c'est-à-dire mes héroïnes elles
sont ancrées dans leur territoire donc
on je pense qu'on les appréhende mieux
on les voit et alors vous assumez
parfaitement me semble-t-il je vous pose
la question mais le caractère populaire
de la litière Arthur que vous écrivez la
preuve c'est que vous faites chacun de
vos romans fait écho par son titre à
soit une chanson là en l'occurrence
c'est un titre d'Indochine mais tous les
titres sont empruntés soit à une chanson
de variété soit une chanson de pop
musique qui est une manière de d'assumer
parfaitement le caractère populaire de
la littérature que vous écrivez oui
c'est vrai bon je l'assume complètement
là après peut-être le fait vous l'avez
rappelé d'être universitaire au départ
d'avoir été pendant 25 ans de ma vie un
professeur très sérieux côtoyant des des
esprits brillants les évaluons des
thèses etc ça va débarrasser de cette
espèce de légitimité de mesure
il faut intelligent il faut savoir
parler avec des mots savants etc ça a
été ma vie et voilà j'avais fait pas
cette eau là donc du coup le fait
d'écrire la littérature populaire me va
très bien voilà fait pas cette recherche
de reconnaissance on va dire académique
puisque je l'ai eu dans mon premier
métier et puis après quand vous l'avez
bien rappelé c'est vrai que la
littérature populaire et notamment le
genre à suspense d'intrigues c'est
vraiment vieux comme la littérature
c'est-à-dire évidemment il va mettre
l'Iliade l'Odyssée mais même si après
les tragédie grecques ce sont des romans
policiers enfin toute la mythologie
grecque et toutes les mythologies du
monde ce sont des trahisons des meurtres
des rebondissements le cheval de Troie
c'est un twist voilà
donc toute la littérature est basée et
c'est assez récemment et je pense
notamment avec l'avènement du livre de
poche de la littérature comme
émancipation du plus grand nombre qu'on
a commencé à faire des des cases en
disant il y aura une littérature pour le
peuple pour le plus grand nombre et il y
aura peut-être une littérature un peu
plus élitiste pour garder
et ce qui est dommage que comme le
nombre de lecteurs se réduit et bien si
on enferme peut-être un peu trop dans
une littérature élitiste au risque de se
retrouver avec de moins en moins de
lecteurs et que cette ce grand talent de
la littérature pourrait émanciper le
plus grand nombre il va se reporter vers
les séries télé il va se reporter vers
d'autres moyens et peut-être pas vers la
littérature donc il faut qu'il y ait
toutes les littérature mais surtout de
créer ou pas des cases pour dire aux
gens qui lisent de la littérature
populaire ce que vous lisez ma foi c'est
quand même pas extraordinaire et vous
pourriez aller vers d'autres littérature
surtout pas parce que l'essentiel de la
littérature c'est d'abord voilà cet
évasion Adrien vous qui êtes membre de
l'Académie vous pensez pas que des
Beaux-Arts de l'Institut vous pensez pas
que quelqu'un que Michel Bussi j'aurais
figure honorablement à l'Académie
française est-ce qu'il va falloir
attendre comme pour comme pour Dumas ou
pour Eugène Sue des décennies avant de
lui reconnaître la légitimité qui est la
sienne il y a quelqu'un qui nous
admirons l'un et l'autre Michel et moi
qui au toute sa place à l'Académie
française c'est Maurice Leblanc oui qui
est très populaire qui a toutes les
ficelles du roman feuilleton mais qui se
sent l'héritier de Maupassant de
Flaubert de Balzac enfin qui a qui
n'était pas de l'Académie française
aucun des trois mais il est le
continuateur d'une vraie tradition
littéraire qui survit dans le roman
policier le roman a connu toutes ses
révolutions mais un certain type de
romans est toujours là celui où on vous
fait découvrir des personnages étranges
celui où vous arrivez dans des dans des
milieux un peu secrets interdits
exactement ce que vous disiez Michel
c'est moi je vote c'est l'entrée de
Michel à l'Académie mais mais supposé
qu'il en ait envie mais mais une
question alors justement le blanc vous
n'avez pas choisi le personnage
récurrent donc vous chacun de vos romans
réinvente l'enquêteur c'est vous avez
hésité ou c'était naturel pour vous de
faire ce choix il y a eu un rassard
c'est à dire qu'au départ j'ai commencé
par être dédicité dans une édition
régionale en Normandie et les éditions
des et des premiers romans qui
s'appelait mourir sur scène qui se
passait pendant l'arbada de Rouen avait
eu l'héroïne qui devait devenir une
héroïne récurrente qui était une
journaliste balise à Bruges je m'étais
dit tiens c'est bien je vais faire mon
petit écrivain normand et elle ira
enquêter sur Étretat il y a enquêter sur
Dieppe sur le Mont-Saint-Michel enfin
voilà donc on était proche de ce que
fait Adrien donc il y a eu cette idée et
puis j'ai commencé comme ça puis à un
moment donné il y a eu l'idée de
d'affaires qui était un roman qui se
passait à Giverny et j'ai hésité entre
une aventure de plus de enfin une
seconde aventure de manière brusque qui
est à l'état d'ébauche et d'un fait
avoir et puis à un moment donné je me
suis dit dans falloir bâtir beaucoup
plus c'était l'espèce de robot à twist
et il a fait avoir et c'était le début
d'une reconnaissance un peu nationale et
à partir de là la pauvre la pauvre
héroïde récurrente et reste au placard
et comme avec ma falloir j'étais un peu
étiqueté robancier à twist robancier
dont la fin est surprenante je pouvais
plus avoir un enquêteur récurrent il
fallait qu'à chaque fois qu'un de mes
lecteurs prennent le robot il se disent
qu'est-ce qui va se passer est-ce que le
narrateur c'est le coupable est-ce que
le narrateur enfin voilà est-ce que je
suis manipulé depuis le début et si vous
avez
un enquêteur récurrent vous pouvez faire
plein de choses mais difficilement le
faire mourir difficilement le faire
passer pour en tueur en série enfin
voilà vous êtes contraint par ce genre
et vous avez un peu moins de liberté
dans dans cette histoire de de faux
semblant et donc je me suis peut-être
moi-même enfermé dans un genre mais en
fait tous les écrivains sont fermés dans
un genre parce que on a plaisir à à
refaire ce qu'on a à ce que les lecteur
web forcément alors Adrien vous au
contraire vous vous inscrivez vous dans
l'idée de la série puisque votre
enquêtrice c'est toujours la même c'est
Pénélope Pénélope qui est conservatrice
du patrimoine qui est historienne de
l'art et qui a finalement dans son
métier les mêmes méthodes que qu'une
enquêtrice elle va chercher des indices
elle va faire des hypothèses donc
évidemment elle sera jamais soupçonnée
d'être la coupable mais dans ce dernier
volume de ces enquêtes intrigue
abréganson c'est son éternel fiancé son
petit copain qui lui va être soupçonné
il s'appelle Vandry
il est fils de ministre et donc à
Brégançon on le regarde avec un peu de
prudence et mais malgré tout il est très
suspect dans cette affaire mais alors
votre type de roman policier n'est pas
du tout celui de Michel Auchan ou
l'intrigue est construite certes mais
elle compte moins que ce dont elle est
prétexte la promenade j'aime beaucoup
que ça se retourne à la fin qui est
rebondissements imprévus et ça je l'ai
appris comme Michel en lisant Arsène
Lupin et Maurice Leblanc dans une
nouvelle comme l'écharpe de soi rouge de
Maurice Leblanc il y a peut-être 5 ou 6
retournement de situation et ça n'est
qu'une nouvelle donc il y a un art très
consommé d'un certain roman policier à
la française Gaston Leroux ou le tabbit
Maurice Leblanc Arsène Lupin tout ça
c'est c'est une c'est une vraie
tradition alors évidemment on commence
toujours par un décor par un lieu par
qui suscite des émotions et des
impressions donc Pénélope avait commencé
par la Tapisserie de Bayeux elle se
demandait ce est devenu les quelques
maîtres de toile qui manquent à cette
broderie du 11e siècle elle a été
agiverny elle a été à Giverny parce que
pour avoir lu effectivement le roman sur
la Tapisserie de Bayeux le
rebondissement final et l'explication
finale est absolument géniale merci
Michel
pour rien c'est Pénélope et l'énigme et
l'énigme de Brégançon il y a une énigme
mais il y a une énigme historique aussi
qui a raison pour laquelle le président
de la République Charles de Gaulle a
choisi tout à coup de créer une
résidence dans laquelle il n'a jamais
mis les pieds on ne se pose jamais cette
question c'est-à-dire que c'est un
1964 pour les 20 ans du débarquement de
Provence que le général de Gaulle passe
une nuit dans ce fort que gérait la la
marine qu'un sénateur Robert Bélanger
avait loué et transformé pendant des
années et puis il décide d'en faire la
maison de bord de mer des présidents de
la République sans y jamais y retourner
en effet et surtout ce qu'on n'est
jamais compris pourquoi c'est ça le le
mystère c'est quel besoin la République
à cette date-là avait-elle d'une maison
de vacances face à la Méditerranée alors
j'ai mes hypothèses évidemment et
pourquoi est-ce que cette maison se
transmet de président en président
est-ce que il n'y a pas quelque part
dans ce fort un secret qui ne devrait
être connu quand on regardera bien de
dire vous n'avez jamais Michel vous
n'avez jamais eu la tentation de faire
vous êtes géographe mais n'est jamais eu
la tentation de faire un roman policier
à caractéristique alors à
caractéristique pas aussi clairement
mais oui bah moi j'adore ce genre de
l'intrigue et j'ai écrit un roman qui
fait tout ce qui est sur terre doit
périr qui part de l'Arche de Noé donc
qui qui se passe aujourd'hui mais qui
est quand même sur une intrigue
historique sur l'énigme le point de
départ et les sables on sait que l'arche
de Noé ce serait échoué en haut du
mont-arrates et avec réchauffement
climatique fond de glace on commence à
voir ce qu'il y a réellement en haut du
bois rarate et là il y a toute une série
de religieux enfin de qui commence à
paniquer
l'histoire de l'Arche de Noé des
chercheurs c'est fascin parce que il y a
des tas des lumineux depuis des siècles
qui ont très tendu avoir trouvé les
marches la clé du mystère soit dans les
siècles passés et qu'au fond c'est pas
des romans historiques mais la clé de
l'énigme mais dans l'histoire toujours
est-ce que vous vous revendiquez parce
que vous faites des romans chics tout de
même référence
cultiver les traits très accessible très
très référence à la fin mais c'est
toujours
à l'histoire à la politique est-ce que
vous vous revendiquez de la littérature
populaire mais j'espère oui bien sûr
mais au sens encore une fois ben d'un
Maurice Leblanc ou d'un Gaston Leroux
c'est de la vraie littérature et et
Balzac aussi encore une fois l'Auberge
rouge une ténébreuse à faire c'est des
romans feuilleton et des romans
policiers l'Auberge rouge c'est le
premier cadavre dans une chambre fermée
de l'intérieur et ses Balzac qui est qui
en a l'idée et et et vos collègues de
l'académie de l'Institut considèrent
dans votre œuvre cette série
légal de vos autres productions
intellectuelles passionnés de Maurice
Leblanc il y a Michel zinc par exemple
qui est parfaitement
[Musique]
à l'Académie des sciences morales et
politiques j'en suis là qui est un féru
de Arsène Lupin et de romans populaires
donc voilà il y a des fautes débarrasser
de ces catégories qui n'ont plus lieu
d'être et on a c'est le plaisir de lire
qui compte c'est ça aussi c'est que on
est on s'embarque dans une aventure donc
vous votre votre maître en littérature
policière c'est le blanc alors je dirais
oui je crois vraiment je l'aime beaucoup
c'est la lecture de l'Aiguille Creuse
quand j'étais au collège je me suis dit
qu'il y avait le trésor des rois de
France à découvrir que l'aiguille
d'Étretat était
sanctuaire enfin tout ça j'ai moi j'y ai
cru j'y crois peut-être encore et vous
Michel quels ont été vos inspirateurs
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a créé chez
vous l'envie d'écrire de la littérature
policière
il y en a beaucoup il y a eu Agatha
Christie il y a eu aussi souvent
Sébastien Jaffrelot parce que c'est
celui qui écrit le celui qui écrit il
était meurtrier ou alors dimanche de
fiançailles qui est sans doute celui qui
fait des romans qui sont le plus proche
de ce que j'essaie de faire en tout cas
les Boris Leblanc moi j'ai je lui dois
beaucoup parce qu'en fait mon premier
roman Collin je l'ai écrit en relisant
les décisions de nibus de pour le Center
verset de Lupin en 2005 et en relisant
celle du pape non seulement je vais
cette idée de me dire je vais faire une
géographie de harcèle Lupin mais je me
suis dit ce type est un génie c'est à
dire de se dire vous avez lu ça quand
j'avais 15 ans ou 13 ans le blanc est un
génie il invente tout et ensuite que
notre Doyle comme un peu plus littéraire
parce que bah les Américains les Anglais
savent très bien il y a pas un mot trop
il y a des dialogues
à Christie oui parce que le Fort de
Brégançon où j'ai eu le privilège de
résider un peu d'y dormir
c'est un monde clos inaccessible et une
petite digue c'est très sécurisé on a
très envie de de mettre un cadavre au
centre et de se dire que tous ceux qui
sont présents dans ce roman il y a une
éditrice il y a un photographe il y a
deux gardiens qui ne ressemblent pas du
tout à ceux qui sont réellement les
gardiens du Fort de Brégançon sont des
gens charmants que je salue
et vous avez envie de dire être à
nouveau invités
j'avais demandé si je pouvais y aller et
le directeur des résidences
présidentielles m'avait dit mais oui
bien sûr voilà c'était en l'absence du
chef de l'État que grâce à vous on
découvre tout un monde le directeur des
résidences financières le le Fayet toute
une série d'administrations
c'est la mission de Pénélope elle doit
refaire le décor parce que il y a des
strates dans le fort de Briançon il y a
un goût Bernadette Chirac il y a un goût
anémone Giscard d'Estaing tout ça c'est
superposé et là grand coup de balai on
veut moderniser apporter des choses
contemporaines voilà donc c'est assez
drôle il y a un passage sur le rideau et
des gardiens qui est vrai
ce qui concerne les rideaux est
impeccablement vérifié est-ce que la
passion de Pénélope et du et du roman
policier est en train progressivement de
de contaminer votre oeuvre et de prendre
la place de tous les ouvrages d'octes
que vous devriez écrire vous arrivez à
maintenir ou maintenez quand même de la
place pour le reste je continue à écrire
des des articles sérieux dans des
catalogues d'exposition dans
l'exposition Ingres qui va commencer à
Chantilly le mois prochain j'ai fait un
article que je crois sérieux dans
l'exposition sur le prince Napoléon qui
va commencer à Ajaccio au palais fech
cet été je suis un des commissaire de
cette exposition et j'ai fait des
articles qui sont multiples
universitaires
est-ce que tout à coup vous dites ah
tiens le palais pêche ah oui
électorale de Michel ça donne envie de
rêver sur des cartes et de rêver sur des
archives et de se dire qu'il y a plein
d'histoires qu'on peut raconter alors
nous allons poursuivre cette
conversation avec une lectrice Mona qui
a une question et je crois que cette
question est pour Michel Menin on vous
écoute
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Mona j'ai 21 ans je
suis étudiante en lettres et en
parallèle de mes études je travaille en
médiathèque autant dire que les livres
me suivent un peu partout tout le temps
et depuis toujours mon premier souvenir
de lecture c'est le compte de
Monte-Cristo après avoir vu le téléfilm
à la télé si mes grands-parents fallait
absolument que je dise le livre et
depuis j'ai surtout lu de la littérature
classique mais de plus en plus elle
était littérature contemporaine et
engagée j'ai lu le dernier livre de
Michel Bussi trois vie par semaine jolie
clin d'oeil à Indochine qui est un roman
à suspense qui nous invite à tirer les
fils pour découvrir
les raisons de la mort d'un homme qui se
révèle à voir trois identités trois vies
et trois femmes différentes j'ai
beaucoup aimé l'intrigue a le temps de
ce livre mais surtout la place qui est
donnée au handicap un livre à la fois
moteur de l'intrigue et de sa résolution
c'est un roman qui se passe à la fois
dans le Cantal mais aussi à Paris et à
Charleville-Mézières surtout en Ardennes
c'est la vie dont tu es issue Arthur
Rimbaud dont les citations viennent
ponctuer tout le livre la première
station du livre c'est jeu est un autre
mais celle-ci bonjour vous introduisez
cette citation au tout début de votre
livre avez-vous l'impression que lorsque
vous écrivez ces personnages c'est une
démultiplication de vous et donc ce sont
vos autres
ce type d'écrivain qui va essayer de de
garder les personnages en laisse ce
roman parle beaucoup des marionnettes on
a une marionnettes en couverture et ça
peut ça voilà le robots pour moi c'est
un baronetti donc je suis le maillot des
tige je suis caché on voit pas et par
contre mais personnages moi je vois
l'envers du décor je vois les boules de
scotch je vois les ficelles les agrafes
par contre le spectateur ou le lecteur
lui il ne voit qu'un personnage il y
croit il pleure si le personnage meurt
même si c'est un personnage de chiffon
de papier ou de d'encre il pleure mais
moi je connais je peux changer jusqu'au
dernier moment le prénom la couleur des
yeux donc je suis beaucoup moins ému par
les personnages que de les lecteur après
je vais plein d'écrivains qui disent
c'est l'inverse mais moi comme j'ai mon
intrigue que je dois suivre de façon
assez précise faites bien je sais que
tel personnage va tomber amoureux telle
personnage va mourir et généralement ils
sont assez peu de liberté alors bien sûr
après on se laisse charmer par les
personnages mais bah contrainte
généralement c'est quand même justement
d'être le Mario des pistes et vous c'est
le compte de Monte-Cristo parfaitement
raison cette lectrice c'est tout est
déjà là le jeudi d'identité le
changement les masques le changement le
retour du compte de Monte-Cristo Edmond
Dantès est oublié mais c'est le même
personnage est-ce que vous vous diriez
comme Bovary comme Flaubert à propos des
Pénélope c'est vous un sans doute oui je
pense oui oui mais beaucoup d'autres
personnages aussi on met toujours
beaucoup de choses très personnelles
qu'on croit caché dans dans les
aventures policières le roman policier
est bien pour ça
voilà malheureusement cette émission
s'achève mais avant nous nous quittions
l'habitude ici c'est que nous
recommandions à nos lecteurs enfin nous
à ceux qui nous suivent plutôt un goût
de lecture une lecture que nous avons
faite et que nous avons envie de
partager un coup de cœur mais attention
c'est satisfait ou remboursé bien sûr il
faut que il faut que après vous avoir lu
le livre que vous leur recommandez ils
se disent waouh donc on va commencer par
vous Michel quel est le livre que vous
proposez à la lecture de ceux qui nous
ont suivis par hasard c'est le Pénélope
voilà il y a pas de donc c'est une
écrivaine qui fabrique jeune qui
s'appelle pédélope rose qui a publié
chez plomb un roman qui s'appelle valse
fauve c'est en 2022 je crois et c'est un
superbe roman qui qui raconte l'histoire
du héroïde pendant une guerre qui ne dit
pas son nom on sait pas vraiment où
c'est ni quand c'est donc c'est assez
onirique et on va raconter cette héroïde
qui va d'abord recueillir à d'enfant
puis être très en dehors de la guerre
puis de voir s'investir dans cette
guerre de venir résistance donc voilà
donc ça un roman avec une écriture très
simple très pure
qui devient très vite de plus en plus
alto et j'étais bluffé par ce premier
roman Adrien moi c'est pas un roman
c'est un essai un essai de claude Arnaud
qu'on connaît comme le grand biographe
de Jean Cocteau et qui dans ce style qui
le fait toujours reconnaître très précis
et brillant mais en scène le combat dans
la reine de Picasso et de Cocteau donc
ça s'appelle Picasso tout contre Cocteau
c'est Sacha Guitry qui aurait pu dire ça
et c'est très intéressant parce que ce
Picasso qu'on accuse beaucoup d'avoir
torturé les femmes et sans doute il l'a
fait a aussi torturé un homme qui est
Jean Cocteau et Jean Cocteau il prend
une forme de plaisir c'est un très beau
livre en effet alors à la rédaction de
au bonheur des livres nous avons choisi
un peu parce que ces thèmes mais ne pas
seulement Jean-Bernard Puy qui est un
des un des des grands auteurs du néopola
dans la dans la postérité de manchette
et d'ADG
vous l'avez lu non non j'ai beaucoup lu
Jean-Bernard
c'est un nanar évidemment c'est la la
tendance de gauche du néopola c'est la
plus dominante d'ailleurs toujours dans
le genre polar et là encore tendance de
gauche petite salle Louise melizmet est
une hauteur de roman policier féministe
dont l'essentiel des des textes sont
autour de la question des violences
faites aux femmes et des je sais pas si
c'est complètement votre tasse
je vous la fais lire
Jacques Fernandez Jacques Fernandez
c'est un classique maintenant de la
bande dessinée il a beaucoup payé qu'il
a beaucoup dessiné autour de la
Méditerranée de l'Algérie dont il est né
de la Provence cher à mon coeur et là
c'est un roman c'est un texte une avec
Attia morissatia c'est un policier qui
se déroule à Alger
très très beau livre ça vous intéresse
aux éditions Flammarion éloge
des vertus minuscules c'est une
professeure de lettres dans une FAQ
américaine qui avait déjà écrit un livre
assez drôle sur l'ennui du lecteur
pourquoi la littérature comment la
littérature accepte d'ennuyer son
lecteur et là c'est sur le assez bien
c'est elle fait l'éloge au lieu de la
perfection de la complicement de la
réussite elle fait l'éloge à travers des
textes solitaires proustes et d'autres
du assez bien je suis sûr que ça va vous
ah oui oui j'ai très envie de le lire
voilà cette émission s'achève merci
adrien Goetz vous publiez aussi
dictionnaire de l'amoureux de la Toscane
Michel Bussi trois vie par semaine c'est
un péche-turner comme on dit donc
évidemment quand on commence on peut pas
s'arrêter c'est je dirais la même chose
Adrien d'ailleurs merci d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci à notre
lectrice et vous pouvez revoir cette
émission sur la plateforme numérique de
Public Sénat public sénat.fr
et sinon nous nous retrouvons la semaine
prochaine
à la même heure à moins que d'ici là
nous ne nous soyons croisés dans une
librairie merci bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres